hi guys welcome back and really glad to
make a youtube video today it's been a
long time I think the last video I made
was with Anthony my friend and there
wasn't proud a couple months ago we're
going to talk about that in a bit but
today I wanted to talk about fluency
what is fluency and I'm going to try to
make this not controversial but actually
useful for language learners now the
reason why I use the word controversial
is the because with the word fluency it
so much happens that a lot of people
debate quibble they say oh this is my
definition my definition is correct your
definition is wrong bla bla bla I think
that's really missing the forest for the
trees I think that there is no one fits
all size fits all definitional fluency
that the truth is that fluency is
something that should be defined by you
and if you define your own concept of
fluency the great thing that is going to
happen is that this is going to help you
actually carry out a an efficient
strategy it's really important in life
to have a precise goal and and this
helps you to define a strategy because
if you have a precise goal this defines
your action so without further ado I
would say that I'm going to give my own
definition of fluency so once again this
is my definition and my definition of
fluency is to be able to actually hold a
conversation to make it flow to
communicate smoothly fluently you know
the word fluent flow with other human
beings which actually implies two things
first that I can get my point across
even if I don't know all the words in
the language and the second thing is
that I can actually understand what is
being said to me now the interesting
thing is that a lot of people think that
fluency is some kind of final goal if
you're fluent you speak you understand
everything and you can say everything
but that is not exactly true let me give
an example I made a youtube video some
time ago maybe three years ago when I
was in Russia and I didn't remember the
word space combination or a mix actually
a mix of something and somebody wrote an
interesting comment which is not it's
not the only time
that comment like that was left under my
video as well as other videos saying
that if you don't know such an easy word
as a mix or mixture or whatever then
you're not fluent but the truth is I
thought well but just wait a second but
I was in rush I could speak I could
interact we talked about with a lot of
Russian Russians about philosophy
religion you name it and then the fact
that I didn't remember the word or
didn't remember I didn't even know the
word mix didn't hamper me from didn't
keep me hamper me from having
conversations and actually communicating
with people I think that in language
learning imagine learning a language
like making pizza you know it's there
are two main things that you have to do
you have to expand and you have to
refine so on the one hand you have this
piece of dough there and you put more
flour into it and the piece of dough
gets bigger but then if you don't refine
it if you don't give it a form then it's
going to be a formless big piece of
dough well if actually you refined you
have a piece of a piece of dough which
is not really big and you work on it you
will have a perfect piece of dough that
is too small so which means that in
terms of language learning it means that
if you learn too many words but you
don't learn how to put them together in
a given context in a conversation to
communicate with other human beings is
what is going to happen is that you know
a lot of words but you can't actually
communicate which is what happens all
the time for example to students who go
to to to school they know a lot of words
they know about the language but they
can't actually use it
this I call explicit knowledge and this
notion of explicit knowledge and
implicit knowledge you can find an
actually in an amazing book which I
can't find exactly right now but it's in
there and it's called Loudon it's a it's
a German book which talks about the fact
that you have explicit knowledge which
is know much about something in this
case about the language about grammar
rules and then actually the implicit
knowledge which is the ability to use
the language so to go back to the pizza
thing if you have a very small piece of
dough
then you have implicit not what you have
developed the capacity of using a few
pieces of information but that implies
that you can have you can rehearse your
kit you can be very good within certain
topics like for example you have you
have your own Islands you can say a lot
of things about a certain topic but if
you get out of your comfort zone or
somebody says something that you've
never heard or you're never talked about
then you get lost so the principle here
my strategy is actually to use implicit
implicit knowledge to develop implicit
knowledge which is the skill of
communicating with a relatively small
amount of words where a relatively small
means hundreds of words and so you build
we build or I build my knowledge upon
that using a few few words or the most
frequent words and I learn how to
communicate with human beings and then I
expand upon that because I still believe
that in order to speak a language well
and to know it well to be able to be
proficient in a language you have to
know a lot of words but proficiency and
fluency are two slightly different
concepts and my friend Anthony talks
about this in the article that he put
together and this article is going to
come out very very soon in a couple of
days I just wanted to anticipate this in
my video and it's going to be a really
cool article because it's not just about
talking it's not just talking about
fluency for the sake of talking about
fluency which leads to you know a lot of
discussions which probably they're not
very not going to be very useful but it
it gives you a very precise definition
of that and it gives you a very precise
strategy in things to do and tools to
use to finally communicate in a language
and fluently so if you want to check
that article you can check it I just put
the link down below on my blog which is
WWWE com I from now on I will try to
make us more videos because I've been I
haven't been very good with that due to
a lot of to a lot of things but you know
I always say that you always find the
time to do things if you want to do them
so I wish you a fantastic day and I will
talk to you very very soon bye